.
ALL RIGHT ROMA TAKE IT OFF OR
YOU LEFT OFF BUT I LOVE THOSE
INTERVIEWS AWESOME HANNITY.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM THIS THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM WASHINGTON I
THINK IS MUCH BEING WITH US.
A APOCALYPSE JILL BIDEN THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: WILL HE OR WON'T HE
WILL JILL BIDEN SEEK A SECOND
TERM OR NOT?
WILL THE WHITE HOUSE'S ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION HAS BEEN WELL,
EVOLVING.
>> President Biden: MY PLAN IS
TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
>> IS AGAIN A RUN IN 2024?
TO GO YES, THAT IS HIS
INTENTION.
>> HIS ANSWER IS BEEN PRETTY
SIMPLE WHICH IS YES.
>> JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION AND I WILL BE HAS
TAKEN MATE.
, LISTEN TO PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
HE INTENDS TO RUN.
AND IF HE DOES I INTEND TO RUN
WITH THEM.
[LAUGHS]
SO THERE YOU GO.
>> AND IF HE DOES I WILL BE
RUNNING WITH THEM PROBABLY.
>> Laura: AND THEN WHEN
DR. JILL WAS ASKED ABOUT A JUST
A FEW DAYS LATER THEY NOTICE
MORE NERVOUS LAUGHTER.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT HIM
WITH IT?
>> I'VE BEEN A LITTLE BIT TOO
BUSY, NOT YET.
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE A
DISCUSSION.
[LAUGHS]
>> Laura: I'M SURE IT'LL BE A
DISCUSSION?
HAS ANYONE TOLD JOE?
>> President Biden: LOOK, MY
INTENTIONS AS I WOULD RUN AGAIN,
BUT IT JUST AN INTENTION.
IS IT A FIRM DECISION?
THAT I'D RUN AGAIN?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
SPIEGELMAN TELL YOU WHAT REMAINS
TO BE SEEN COME JUST TO MANY
SEATS THE DEMOCRATS ARE GONNA
LOSE IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
AND IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WHETHER IF JOE BIDEN IS EVEN
CAPABLE OF STANDING UPRIGHT AT
THIS MOMENT.
NOW HIS COGNITIVE DECLINE EVER
BUT HE KNOWS THAT IT'S OBVIOUS,
HE NEEDS CARDS FOR PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING AND LATELY IT SEEMS
LIKE HE DOESN'T JUST NEED
ELECTORAL SUPPORT FOR WOMEN, BUT
PHYSICAL SUPPORT AS WELL.
MEMBER HE WAS WALKING WITH
MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER THAT
WAS ODD.
BUT TODAY ATTENDING THE QUEEN'S
FUNERAL DR. JILL SEEMS MORE LIKE
NURSEMAID JILL AND FIRST LADY.
THEN REALLY DID YOU NOTED THAT
THE JOE BIDEN'S ACTUALLY ARRIVE
LATE IN LESS THAN A VERY AWKWARD
MOMENT THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES HAD TO STAND AND
BE TOLD TO WAIT.
AS MILITARY HEROES PROTESTANT.
THE GUARDIAN RIDING AFTER
ARRIVING HAND-IN-HAND THE BIDENS
SAT DOWN IN THEIR PLACES AT TEN
OH 5:00 A.M.
THE SCHEDULED BY POKING M PALACE
SAID THE 500 AND VIA DIGNITARY
SHOULD BEEN SEATED BETWEEN
9:35 A.M. AND 9:55 A.M.
PERHAPS AS A CONSEQUENCE OF ITS
THE OPTING ON THE BUSES TAKING
OTHER LEADERS FROM YOUR STUBBLY
POINT OF THE RAW HOSPITAL THE
JOE BIDEN'S WERE ALSO GIVEN
SEATS 14 ROWS BACK.
NOW FOR A PRESIDENT WHO PUBLICLY
PRIDED HIMSELF ON HIS VAST
EXPERIENCE IN FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AFFAIRS THIS WAS
EMBARRASSING.
AND EVEN WHEN NEEDING PHYSICAL
SUPPORT, JOE BIDEN CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON HIS REGIME MEDIA
SUPPORT.
THE GAL KJ JP BECAUSE SCOTT
PELLEY OF CBS SEEMS LIKE HE'S
LISTENING FOR YOUR JOB.
>> SUMMER WAS GOING SO WELL FOR
THE PRESIDENT, THE WHITE HOUSE
THREW A PARTY LAST WEEK WITH A
CONCERT BY JAMES TAYLOR.
YOU HAVE HAD A SLING OF
LEGISLATIVE SUCCESSES RECENTLY.
THE MUCH MORE MODEST BIPARTISAN
GUN LAW THAT PASSES SUMMER MAY
BE THE BEST EXAMPLE OF THE
PRESENCE LEGISLATIVE
BREAKTHROUGHS THAT NO ONE
THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
CATHOLIC AND DEVOUT HE KEEPS A
ROSARY IN HIS POCKET.
>> YOU'VE LIVED A LONG LIFE OF
TRIUMPH AND TRAGEDY.
>> Laura: IN A MOMENT OR EVEN
PELLEY COULDN'T EVEN SAVE
JOE BIDEN FROM HIMSELF.
>> WHICH A CHINESE PRESIDENT
KNOW ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT TO
TAIWAN?
>> President Biden: WE ARE
GREAT AGREED WITH WHAT WE SIGNED
ONTO A LONG TIME AGO.
THERE'S ONE CHINA POLICY AND
TAIWAN MAKES HER OWN JUDGMENTS.
>> WHAT WOULD U.S. FORCES DEFEND
THE ISLAND?
>> President Biden: YES, THERE
WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED ATTACK.
>> UNLIKE HER UKRAINE TO BE
CLOSER, U.S. FORCES THE U.S. MEN
AND WOMEN WOULD DEFEND TAIWAN IN
THE EVENT OF A CHINESE INVASION.
>> President Biden: YES.
>> Laura: OOPS AND THAT BRINGS
US TO --
>> AFTER OUR INTERVIEW A
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL TOLLS THAT
YOU WILL U.S. POLICY HAS NOT
CHANGED.
OFFICIALLY THE U.S. WILL NOT SAY
WHETHER AMERICAN FORCES WOULD
DEFEND TAIWAN.
>> Laura: I THINK THIS IS THE
FOURTH TIME THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
BOLLIX THE TAIWAN QUESTION.
THAT'S OKAY IT WAS ONLY RISKING
SERVING A WAR WITH CHINA IT'S
OKAY.
ALL THE MEDIA SPIN AND ALTHOUGH
SOFTBALL QUESTIONS LOOK, IT
CAN'T CHANGE REALITY JUST 50
DAYS BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
BEYOND THE SO THE GLOBAL ELITES
AMERICA UNDER JOE BIDEN IS
BECOMING ITS OWN SCAPE OF
ECONOMIC PAIN.
AN ARTICLE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" WAS SO
UPSETTING TO ME TONIGHT THAT I
HAD TO SHARE WITH YOU.
WITH SINGLE MOMS WAS ASKED ABOUT
HER GROCERY TRIP SHE STARTED
TEARING UP.
GOT TO THE POINT WHERE I JUST
BREAK DOWN THE SITE HAD WE DO
IT?
SHE IS TAKING ON EXTRA WORK,
PAINTING, AND LANDSCAPING TO
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE.
AND THEN THERE'S THE
HEARTBREAKING STORY OF JESSICA
BOUDREAU HER OTHER SON AND HER
GRANDSON ARE MOVING IN WITH HER
SOON IT'S DOESN'T KNOW HOW SHE
CAN AFFORD TO FEED EVERYONE.
LUCKILY MY GRANDBABY IS ONLY TWO
SO HE DOESN'T EAT A LOT.
MAYBE, JUST MAYBE THE PARTY
PLANNING THAT THE SOAP PRO WOMEN
SHOULD ADMIT PAY ATTENTION
MAKING IT EXPERIENCE.
THE GENERAL PORTS THAT THEY NOT
SPEND MORE OF HER GROCERIES HER
FAMILY OF EIGHT AND UNDER $1500
MONTHLY MORTGAGE.
STUFF HAVE A GUN AT JUST A
LITTLE BIT, IT'S GONE UP
TREMENDOUSLY.
THE HOMEMAKER SAYS.
THESE ARE REAL AMERICAN STORIES
AND ONCE IN A WHILE REPORTER
FROM ANOTHER NETWORK WILL
ACTUALLY DO HIS JOB.
>> IF YOU CANNOT BLAME
EVERYTHING ON THE PANDEMIC FOR
INFLATION BECAUSE ANY OF THEIR
ACKNOWLEDGED REOPENING AFTER THE
PANDEMIC IS WHY WE JUST GOT BACK
TO BASICALLY THE JOB THAT WE HAD
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
>> WE ARE PUTTING OURSELVES ON A
BETTER PATH NOW.
>> Laura: A BETTER PATH?
IS THAT WHAT SHE SAID?
WELL SWEETHEART VOTERS DON'T
THINK SO.
>> WE ASKED THIS QUESTION ABOUT
JOE BIDEN THE EFFECT THE
POLICIES OF HAD IN THE TWO
MARGIN FOLKS SAYING IT'S HURT
THE ECONOMY AND HELP THE
ECONOMY.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THEY ARE
SAYING THAT THE INCESSANT
DRUMBEAT OF THE PAST SEVERAL
WEEKS IS THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SOMEHOW TURNING THE CORNER.
>> FOR MONTHS REPUBLICANS WERE
SURE THAT THEY BE SERVING A RED
WAVE, BUT NOW IT JUST 51 AGO
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY THINK THAT
THEY'RE BACK IN THE GAME.
AND HERE IS WHY.
>> IT'S GONE, DEMOCRATS A GOOD
CHANCE OF HOLDING THE SENATE,
MAY BE PICKING UP A COUPLE OF
SEATS.
>> MAY BE IF WILL HAPPEN.
>> Laura: ARIZONA, AND
GEORGIA, THEY ARE TIGHTENING
THEIR FORCE REPORT AT THE ANGLE
HAS BEEN PREDICTING FOR WEEKS
THAT WAS RIGHT.
NOW THAT SUMMER IS OVER THE
HARSH COLD REALITY OF AMERICAN
LIFE OF THIS DEMOCRAT MAJORITY
STARTING TO SET IN.
REPUBLICANS ARE WELL-POSITIONED
COMFORTABLY WENT BACK THE HOUSE
AND ON A SURE FOOTING THAT JUST
WEEKS AGO THE NUMBER 1 SEED
NECESSARY TO CAPTURE THE ONE
SENATE MAJORITY.
THE CONCERN OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE SENATE WAS TO GET
INVOLVED HAS APPARENTLY AWAKENED
MITCH McCONNELL.
NOT ONLY IS HE HOLDING IT
ANOTHER FUND-RAISER FOR BLAKE
MASTERS IN ARIZONA, BUT AGAIN
THEY ARE REPORTING ANOTHER
ARTICLE TONIGHT THAT HE IS
ACTUALLY HAVING SOME CLOSED-DOOR
CONFIDENCE OVER THE G.O.P. WHEN
HE BACKED THE SENATE NOW.
WE TOLD YOU.
OVER THE RECENT LOOK, THEY'VE A
WINNING ARGUMENT.
AT LAST WEEK'S FOX POLL SO THE
59% OF VOTERS THEY WERE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH
INFLATION AND HIGHER PRICES OF
COURSE.
FULLY 5% SAID THE SAME ABOUT
ABORTION POLICY.
IN HER REPUBLICANS ARE TRUSTED
MORE ON THE ECONOMY BY A MARGIN
OF 14 POINTS, THE 52-38
ACCORDING TO NEW POLLING LINEAR
TIMES.
THE ECONOMY, CRIME, AND THE
BORDER SHOULD BE RL ALL THAT
REPUBLICANS HIT AND HIT HARD
FROM NOW UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
ANYTHING ELSE FRANKLY IS JUST A
DISTRACTION.
THE FIRST TIME CANDIDATES THAT
THE REPUBLIC AND PARTY IS
NOMINATED AT SAID OLD AND NOT
GOOD ENOUGH LOOK AT, THEY NOT
SQUISHES THEY WANT REAL CHANGE
IS THE TIME FOR SMALLER FORMS
THAT IS OVER.
WE ARE TO SAVE AMERICA ALL OVER
AGAIN AND FRANKLY THAT'S CAN
REQUIRE BIG REFORMS.
THE RADICALS THOUGH NOW RUNNING
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IT'S EASY TO
POINT OUT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE COMING RECESSION AND THE
VIOLENT CRIME THAT'S TEARING
APART THE AMERICAN LANDSCAPE.
THE TEARS ARE WELLING UP IN THE
EYES OF WORRIED MOTHERS AND
GRANDMOTHERS ALL THE CONCERN
FELT BY FATHERS AND YOUNG
PEOPLE, AND ENTREPRENEURS.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE JUST STARTING
OUT THE ARE THE DIRE